ليله مشتعله وروايتان متضاربتان لمعركه
كييفل الجويه اعلان الجيش الاوكراني عن
اسقاط 18 صاروخا روسيا في هجمه وصفت
بالاستثنائيه اعلان نفته روسيا مؤكده ان
ضرباتها الدقيقه دمرت دفاعات كييف الجويه
كما دمرت منظومه امريكيه وذخيره غربيه
ومخازن اسلحه قائله انها اعترضت سبعه
صواريخ من طراز ستوم شادو بريطانيه
[موسيقى]
على الارض لا يوجد ما يثبت ايا من
الادعاءات السابقه بل العكس
اذا عمدا كل طرف منذ بدايه الحرب الى عرض
بيانات تؤكد تقدمه على حساب الاخر تحت ما
تعرف بحرب المعلومات ففي الاشهر الاولى
وتحديدا يونيو من العام الماضي دعت روسيا
سياده الجويه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه بعد
تدمير اسطولها الجوي الادعاء لن يد طويلا
تم ضحضه برص طائرات اوكرانيه تنفذ هجمات
على مناطق حدوديه بالقرب من خط المواجهه
في
ولعل التفسير لهذه الادعاءات كان اقرب لشن
حرب نفسيه من كونها عسكريه حيث ان الارقام
الروسيه لم تخلو من المبالغه وفقا لتقارير
دوليه في البيان الاوكراني الاخير حددت
نوعيه الصواريخ الروسيه الثمانيه عشر التي
تم اسقاطها ومن بينها كنجال هنا يقول احد
المحللين ان القائد الاوكراني ربما خطر
بسمعته منضمه الى الساسه والاعلاميين في
حرب معلومات هدفها الطعنو بقدره الدفاعات
الروسيه
الحقيقه الوحيده في الحرب الاوكرانيه ان
ايا من الطرفين غير قادر على حسم المعركه
لصالحه الامر الذي يؤكد ان حرب المعلومات
اقوى بكثير من الحرب على الارض كالربح
النووي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات